[Music]
please
hands
[Music]
stay
up
get out of here
[Music]
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's so mourn
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
oh my god
this is about a king
and rivers to match
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
oh take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
i got you
so
[Music]
can't believe we're having a baby you're
gonna be the best mom ever
gotta wear
[Music]
jackson police chief is taking questions
now on my watch i will always protect
the city and it's all for you
it's tyrone they got candice i need that
debt you owe me
what did you do to my wife
what do you want connor hey brother i
need your help
i need two million dollars by midnight
there's only one team i know that can
pull this off cap where is she
we're all watching you chief we're all
watching you show's over
everything we've done till now has been
under the cover of the flag
but this is outside the law
so what's the plan we need guns
smash and grab
business as usual
this can get ugly
[Music]
you have no idea who you robbed
you left a loose end
i don't leave luke sans i'm gonna get my
money
i want to see her right now you shoot it
[Music]
you walk away she dies so what we don't
do we got the element of surprise
and we got violence you ready
[Music]
knowing what battles to fight that's
critical
[Music]
here comes cavalry made of course
you're not gonna say anything
[Music]
i know everything that goes on in these
streets
i was trained for war
i fight to win
[Music]
you've been all over the world
you could have a shop anywhere you like
and yet you're here
it doesn't terribly much matter where i
am
i have machias
what else does a man need besides the
shears
this isn't art
this is a craft
you cannot make something good
until you understand the customer
do we let all of our customers keep
black boxes in back
if we only allowed angels to be
customers soon we'd have no customers at
all
please says i don't want any trouble
i need you to listen carefully
there are a thousand blue boys out there
hunting for this and if they find it i
start shooting you follow making matters
worse there are a thousand racket boys
hunting for it too and if they find it
they start shooting you follow you don't
want to be involved in whatever it is
you do
you know exactly what it is that we do
whoa
full house tonight
have you ever heard of the outfit the
outfit is the network of every big-time
crew from santa monica to coney island
and tonight they sent us a message
they're hiding something my friend
i'm gonna need that tape pal right now
why don't you try and take it gentlemen
it's gonna be a long night
sell him up
what
i caught
sell him up
you need to tell me what really happened
in here tonight
now
we got five seconds to tell me what
happened out in the trunk what open the
trunk and grab his arms or i'm hiding
two bodies five a number of things about
me that you don't know
four where's the tape for instance three
i'm telling you the truth
you wanna survive the night
you look them dead in the eyes and you
pretend you're one of them
farmer's daughter take one
i need to be famous wayne
all the best people are ain't nobody
else out there like you
you know why why
because you got that x factor
that days of struggling may soon be over
hollywood here we go
this is it our own studio background
i'm looking for a place to stay
oh yes sir
that's one of this home [ __ ]
and my wife pearl was next door so i
would appreciate a little discretion
you don't know what we're doing does he
well it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission
would you like to
come inside
my surprise
i want to be in the movie well you can't
the story can't just change midway
through
[Music]
if daddy catches us
there's no telling what he might do
my wife is not well
it happens after darkness
[Music]
you don't want to leave do you people's
eyes are gonna pop out of there damn
skulls when i see this
what
are you all right
now
[Music]
boys find this inside what do you think
is on it
i see one goddamn [ __ ] up horror
picture
[Music]
in our gracious state of georgia
our god-given land
the lord has offered us domestic
livestock
we have to go
you must hit your head real hard
do you know you're in georgia
do you know it's 1973.
well i'm gonna need you to fill this out
for me
i don't ride
i can help you
with knowledge we spent decades trying
to make a change for the people
i know exactly who i am and where i came
from
who are you there
i'm free
how do i look
like you
[Music]
it's the woman you used to own alice
you've watched us get tormented
it's my turn
i'm going back
that's a death
[Music]
and that should
scare you
you're not gonna leave here in one piece
this tradition was born loudly for you
it's all coming down
i
am freedom
[Music]
blues
why did it come from
nobody know
blues songs tell you a story some of
about the good and some of them about to
ban which is life
buddy guy right this way folks
[Applause]
i grew up on the plantation in louisiana
i didn't know where to get that was
until i got a certain age
i would take full nails so i just tried
any kind of wire to make it so i could
hear
body guy is he's a revelation he is the
moses of the blues he literally parts
the seed he's the one that created a
certain frequency a certain vocabulary
jimi henderson would tell you man it
wouldn't be me without this cat you know
i didn't really know about buddy guy and
when i delve into him i started going to
record stores and and finding out about
a lot of artists that i didn't know
existed i was like why don't we know
about these people why aren't they
playing on the radio
this traveling life buddy wants to
inspire as many young people to do what
he's doing whoever he hears about yeah
come on up and play well he got to be
one of the best guitar players i've ever
heard but he still views himself as the
kid among muddy waters and holland wolf
because he was the kid hey buddy what's
up man how are you doing man man i'm
hanging in there
man
hopefully i can get quinn a few more
young people to hang on so they the
young generation people will know
oh this is where it came from
buddy used to tell me in case who died
first don't let the blues down the wolf
told me that junior used to tell me that
so from that group who's the left uh
[Music]
me
music speaks in all languages
i'm just blessed to be able to play
guitar well enough with somebody to
listen
i made muddy waters i promise
i got to keep on picking
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
[Music]
can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
evelyn
i'm not your husband i'm an illusion if
i'm from another universe i'm here
because we need your help
[Music]
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evelyn's
you can access all their memories their
emotions
even their skills
there's a great evil spreading the many
verses
and you
maybe your only chance of stopping it
don't make me fight you i am really good
i don't believe you
the universe he speaks of senseless
things is so much bigger
than you realize
of all the places i could be
[Music]
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
motives
there is no way i am the eveline you are
looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
once upon a time
once upon a time
once upon a time
good morning jane good morning seth
okay
yes madam i'll be on my own eleven
o'clock we're late my dear certainly the
place you drive we will be you're a
writer yes i write
and when did you become a writer i don't
know
yes you do
what glorious day it's turned out to be
we're happy to wait a little longer for
him and he's studying is he that's what
he calls it
[Applause]
madam
[Music]
what are you doing studying and i'm here
to help you study you're what i intend
to study today
i could tell you all my secrets all the
things nobody says
he's not studying he's just late don't
be too cross with him he loves you very
much
jane i've got to get married that's
what's expected of yes
[Music]
you did not say that though i did say
that though
[Music]
we're all so excited for the wedding
you're making us all so happy
you have absolutely nothing to lose that
is a gift and you must learn to use it
i'm so sorry jane but i have some
distressing news
i've been thinking it might be time for
me to leave sir in another house
in a bookshop sir this could be your
greatest book
once upon a time
once upon a time
once upon a time
[Music]
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub during
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model dash mcmahon
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up that's like oh
my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
loretta sage is missing i'm gonna rescue
her i just want her to think of me as
more than a cover model that stands even
dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm sort
of like crossfit
i have snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that come on
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off
i can feel them
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh
oh
oh
the red sage getting you out of here why
are you so massive my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
[Music]
you